[MUSIC]
TODD KERPELMAN:
Hello I/O viewers.
Well, what better
way to follow up
an interview with a
real-life astronaut
than to check out a
virtual spaceship?
So I am here with Amanda in
the augmented reality booth,
and you're going to show me
something cool from the NASA
website.
AMANDA LE: Yeah.
So here you can see on the
NASA website they're showing
3D models of their rovers.
Here we have the
Curiosity Rover,
and they're actually using
the model VR web component
to put that 3D asset
on their website.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well
that's very cool.
Now, you said it's
a web component, so
do they need to NPM install
something to get it working,
or?
AMANDA LE: It's actually markup,
so very simple to just put
on your website.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
Oh, that's very cool.
And this 3D model, what
file format is that?
AMANDA LE: So we
recommend using glTF,
but it also supports
USDZ and GLB.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
And is that something most
commercial 3D modeling
tools will export to?
AMANDA LE: You should be able
to export to that easily.
TODD KERPELMAN: I see you've got
that little button down there
in the bottom right.
What does that do?
AMANDA LE: So this
actually is the new feature
that we're launching
at I/O today.
And what it allows you
to do is open up what
we call Scene Viewer.
So Scene Viewer allows
you to take this 3D model
and actually place it in
your real world space.
TODD KERPELMAN: Whoa, no way.
AMANDA LE: So here you can see
the Curiosity Rover at scale.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow.
It's like there's a real-life
spaceship here in the booth,
but not really.
It's just very-- actually
very nicely rendered,
and it kind of fooled me.
AMANDA LE: And so you
can actually manipulate
this in your own space.
So you'll see it at full
scale, but you can also
shrink it down so
that it can actually
fit in your living room.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK, yes.
So if I want to put the
Curiosity Rover on my coffee
table, I now can, just by
shrinking it down a little bit.
AMANDA LE: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: And so how did
you get the size specification?
Apparently, this
was built real life,
or this is showing
it in real life
and you're able
to shrink it down?
AMANDA LE: Yes.
So NASA, when they
built the 3D model,
decided to build it at scale.
So that's the model
we're referencing.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
Very cool.
And so if I'm a developer and
I want to turn my model VR
component into this
cool scene viewer,
augmented reality experience,
what do I have to do?
AMANDA LE: So there's no need
to build an app for this.
All you actually do
is go into the markup
and you add the AR
attribute, which is literally
the letters a and r.
TODD KERPELMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
AMANDA LE: So
super simple to do.
TODD KERPELMAN: I take two
letters and I get all that.
AMANDA LE: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
Well that sounds easy.
I think even I could do that.
Well I can use a little
pick-me-up after that demo.
Let's head on over here and see
if I can find some caffeine.
Hey, Ashish.
ASHISH SHAH: How
are you doing, Todd?
TODD KERPELMAN: I am doing well.
I'm already excited
for this demo,
because I see there's an
Espresso machine here.
So walk me [AUDIO OUT] today.
ASHISH SHAH: All right.
So what we are doing
in here is we're
showing an Espresso machine
coming to life in AR,
using this technology
called augmented images.
That's part of VR core.
You want to give it a spin?
TODD KERPELMAN: Let's--
yes, let's check it out.
ASHISH SHAH: All right.
So as soon as you
look at this marker.
TODD KERPELMAN: So you're
showing the image there.
ASHISH SHAH: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's
telling you to look around
ASHISH SHAH: And now it's
annotated the machine
with information
about its features.
TODD KERPELMAN: I can see
the little [INAUDIBLE]
coming to life.
ASHISH SHAH: Yes.
It's telling you about
those controls grinding.
TODD KERPELMAN: And
my dose is controlled?
ASHISH SHAH: And the
precise temperature.
What would you do without that?
And you could actually see
an espresso being made here.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, fantastic.
ASHISH SHAH: This is a really
powerful way for manufacturers
to show features
of their product
which are otherwise
just lost in text.
And this really makes the
product come to life--
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
ASHISH SHAH: --in a
really powerful way.
And so this triggers the
experience once it recognizes.
And now what happens once
this image is recognized,
it starts establishing
a correspondence
between the phone and the image.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
the phone always
knows exactly where
it is in response to--
ASHISH SHAH: With
respect to the image.
And when I say it establishes
a correspondence in terms
of a pose, that's
position and orientation.
So position in like
x-direction and y-direction
and in z-direction.
And also the orientation in
three degrees, like pitch,
yaw and roll.
So the phone knows
exactly where it
is with respect to the marker.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
So this kind of
works best in places
where you sort of have strict
control over the environment
in which this image is going
to appear and what's around it?
ASHISH SHAH: Yes.
If you're trying to
augment real things,
you want to make sure
that the image is
rigid with respect to the
things that you don't augment.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
But if you just want the
image itself specifically
to come to life, that's
all you need to do.
ASHISH SHAH: Absolutely.
So think about a scenario
where you're at a store
and you want to see
what's inside a box.
So you could use an
app to look at the box,
it would recognize
the box as a marker,
and you could actually
have a sneak peek
at like what's inside the box.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK so like the
model could pop out of the box
and I could see--
ASHISH SHAH: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: --exactly what
my waffle iron or toaster--
I need stuff in my kitchen--
that's all going [INAUDIBLE]
ASHISH SHAH: Without
even opening it up.
TODD KERPELMAN: And then I won't
get yelled at by shopkeepers.
ASHISH SHAH: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well,
thank you very much Ashish.
I learned a lot about
augmented reality today.
I'm going to grab this espresso.
Oh, it's not real.
But the coffee beans are.
Can I eat the coffee beans?
ASHISH SHAH: Yes, you can.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm going to
take a few coffee beans to go.
ASHISH SHAH: You can
take the coffee beans.
TODD KERPELMAN: Thank you
very much, livestream.
I'm going to go get caffeinated.
[MUSIC PLAYING]